the reason the chancellor and the
government as a whole are under pressure
over fuel bills is the size of the price
rise that is coming down the track the
price cap is expected to rise by at
least 50 percent taking the average bill
from around 300 pounds a year to around
2 000 pounds a year now that's going to
affect about 60 percent of families and
households in the country who are on the
price gap it's going to be particularly
acute for those on low incomes or in
need of support i'm very grateful that
gary and natasha at waterhouse have
joined us here we're in outside their
home in lincolnshire and just very
quickly natasha you had a medical
condition
that has set the family back just
explain what happened um in 2017 i was
diagnosed with a tumor on the spinal
cord
and subsequently
reduced my mobility
so i had to give up work
and
also my husband gary he gave up work to
care for me during the rehabilitation so
therefore we've lost two salaries and
now
you know on universal credit which
by the time we've paid our rent
and other bills doesn't leave us with an
awful lot so it's going to be very tight
so energy already a struggle frankly and
gary just give us an idea of what your
energy bills are currently and the
contrast from summer to this winter well
during summer our bill was between 33 36
pound a month
we've got our first winter bill in and
it jumped up to 190.
uh taking that into perspective when
you've lost the 80 pound month uh
universal credit uh uplift it's it was
pretty hard
and how do you go about managing
that kind of size of bill and that kind
of increase what choices does it leave
you having to make
i'm having to choose between paying rent
buying food or paying for the heating
when i've got the priorities such as
electricity that's on the meter that we
have to pay for
it doesn't give us much any more ability
at all and natasha your condition means
you need the warmth i need the warmth
for my legs
the way i'd explain it is like if you've
got serious arthritis uh my legs just
lock up if i have not got any warmth so
i need the i need the heat so again it's
very tricky to decide between heat or
food really you receive the warm home
allowance as it is which is 140 pounds a
year as uh this could go up around 10
pounds would that make a difference none
whatsoever totally insignificant
unfortunately and i have a bit helps but
it's not going to make any difference to
one i alter and can i ask just how you
feel about the prospect of potentially
bills which already gone up to record
levels going up 60 percent from the
spring
it's making me anxiety anxious it's
stressful
just don't know which way we're going to
turn
and have you got a message for
government as they they say they're
listening they're going to act on this
what would your message be attached
they really need to help vulnerable
people out there
[Music]
they just really need to get to react do
a reality check on people's uh income
and expenditure i mean people who are
working
again they're probably struggling just
as much as we are
um so the government really need to look
into it
okay thank you so much for talking to us
it's given us a real insight into
how much of an impact energy price
increases have already had
in the last year and are going to have
and the challenge for the government is
they say they want to help those most in
need and that of course no one would
argue isn't necessary but the scale of
these price rises means that all sorts
of families all but the most affluent
are going to feel the impact of the
price hikes that are coming in the
spring